yeah look i was laying like this
and then like right here
i felt a little kick
so maybe you can feel something
[Music]
so
this morning has been a very interesting
morning because uh we're running late to
our 12 week appointment which by the way
12 weeks
we made it to the 12 week mark because
they say after 12 weeks your chances of
a miscarriage drop to about two or three
percent so
such a sense of relief we can start
gearing up to tell you guys which
obviously you guys know by now yeah but
yeah we're planning on telling you guys
once we hit the 14-week mark just to be
like
super mega extra safe but yeah this
morning woke up kind of late took a
shower it took a little long casey went
to go get some starbucks there was a
huge line yeah it was long lines and
that took a while as i was getting ready
so he had to go back home and pick me up
and so now
we're at this very moment we're six
minutes late late to our appointment
um which i'm like oh you gotta hurry up
red lights why do we keep getting red
lights but yeah once we get there
um check in and it's gonna be ultrasound
time we get to see this baby and i hope
we finally get to hear this baby's
heartbeat yes we haven't heard a
heartbeat yet but yeah another thing too
is i forgot my makeup so no makeup and
also freaking beautiful you know that
right thank you
you have to say that though because
you're married to me oh yeah freaking
beautiful last night you woke up in the
middle of the night because i was still
working late and you woke up you just
sat there like just next to me like to
keep me company i guess and i was just
looking at you back looking right back
at you and i was like
yeah you are so freaking beautiful
thank you baby
but the other thing i was gonna say
though i really appreciate that so just
really quick because we're getting
closer to the thing is that i freaking
lost the back piece to my earrings i
only have one earring today that's what
you want to talk just really quick
because like i'm about to go to the
doctor right now so like really really
quick yeah because just to point out
like how funny like this appointment is
so important but yeah we're late
um i left back to my earring
i forgot my makeup
i have to get dropped off
now go to the left this way okay bye
[Music]
it's a strong heart
[Music]
try to wake up the baby
[Music]
[Music]
stretching
[Music]
yeah
that's so cool
all right so today we had a momentous
ultrasound we finally heard the baby's
heartbeat and
oh my god it's just so crazy like i'm
actually really surprised i didn't cry i
really thought i was gonna cry when i
heard the heartbeat yeah i don't know
like i guess i'm still in shock and it's
kind of similar to when i was pregnant
with isaac
because when i was pregnant with him it
never hit me that i was
i was pregnant that i was going to be a
mom that i was a mom to this day that i
have a teenager like it doesn't really
like fully click like the same way that
it clicks with like
other things like
buying our house or getting married or
going to
a location
like a destination that i've always
wanted to go to and then it's like oh my
gosh i'm actually here but like when it
comes to me
creating life
i'm like what
really that's crazy i don't know if that
makes any sense but
it's just weird i think it makes sense i
think uh
like my experience of it today was
was like oh it just became real you know
we heard the heartbeat by the way
i've never
watched videos of what it what
heartbeats sound like oh really yeah in
the ultrasound but it literally sounds
like the baby's making beats yeah
like
no it was tight it was tight
that was cool and i was actually more
amazed at how it sounded to me to my
ears in the room rather than actually
listening to the heartbeat oh that's my
baby's heartbeat yeah um
but
i was like it distracted me it was also
because there was so much bass too when
they turned the volume yeah it really
went like
like that's a strong heartbeat
that's all i could think of the
heartbeat was cool but
seeing the baby move yeah that was a
good one
blew my mind and i was like i actually
fell in love with the baby a little bit
more than
prior to today's appointment i was like
oh my god is that moving on you getting
stretching you know that was so cool and
like it was like such good like
uh like a good capture of it like you
really see it the arms moving the legs
kicking is arching its back extraction
and stuff like you could literally see
the baby doing those things and before
that it was like it's just an idea of a
baby really yeah because i don't haven't
seen it yet you know like i haven't seen
to believe it kind of thing you're not
the one going through all the i'm not
going through anything
before that the only image of it we had
it was like this gummy bear looking
thing you know sounds like it doesn't
resemble a human yeah it doesn't look
like a human yet yeah so
but now
it's like
it hit me hard like we're having a baby
there's i know like it just straight up
looks like a human inside of my body i
really didn't think like at right now at
12 weeks i didn't think that
it would look like a human like that
even though because we have we have a
whole bunch of apps on our phone like
different baby apps and they're always
like showing you what it would look like
if you could see it and they're telling
you like the ears finally in place
before it's like over here it's like
picasso and i was like why we wouldn't
be growing here even though in the app
it does kind of look like a human yeah
already like seeing it on the ultrasound
and seeing
seeing them move is just like
what that's crazy but yeah i was just i
was really like
shocked mostly and the tears didn't come
out i kind of noticed like i haven't
been more emotional like most pregnant
women like with their hormones like
they'll be like easier to
to cry but i've actually found it harder
to cry for me like
i don't know if you should watch up no
like i've seen first 10 minutes of up
that's a good test
if you don't cry in in those 10 minutes
yeah then we know something's wrong yeah
but like i've been watching tv shows or
like movies and stuff and i'm like this
is weird i would normally cry to this
but it's like i'm not crying or like
we'll have like some deep conversations
or something and like you're crying like
they're like and i'm they're like
i'm like putting my head on your
shoulder and you're like comforting me
like yeah it's okay yeah like i don't
know just that's a that's a weird
symptom i i don't know if that's a
symptom but side effect i don't know
another one that's driving me crazy is
my freaking eye it keeps twitching like
insanely twitching my right eye
the top eyelid it just it twitches like
on and off and it's been going on for
weeks and it's just like is this ever
gonna go away because this eye twitch
thing is annoying and i would have never
linked it to the pregnancy but there's
this girl that i follow that i was
switching like crazy for a couple weeks
and then she had some other symptoms
where her husband who's a paramedic like
did like an ekg on her and stuff to see
like is anything wrong with your heart
because i forgot her other symptoms
apparently the eye twitch and then that
other symptom was linked to her being
pregnant she didn't know she was
pregnant i'm not a paramedic but i'm a
video editor so i could do some video
editor behind twitch and see what
happens with that
yeah but like eventually they went to
the hospital and that's when she took a
pregnancy test like oh let's just rule
this out yeah she was like oh my god i'm
pregnant like what the heck pregnancy
and eye twitching is linked somehow
weird but my eye is driving me crazy
it's always switching like
won't stop so it's not like a matter of
eating more potassium bananas
to like well i can't eat bananas either
because they're bad for constipation
which is another symptom
you were buying your bananas like almost
every week yeah
every morning every day in my oatmeal i
was eating bananas and i didn't know
that it was working against me so i
stopped eating bananas i love the
information you're sharing yeah it's
been a it's been fun i mean you guys are
joining the journey too so might as well
let you know everything drew from the
comments i realized there's a lot of you
guys out there that are pregnant with us
and like yeah a lot of times
we're we're
baby months twins or something like i
forgot the term knowledge but basically
buddies bump buddies yeah
partners or whatever that's cool yeah
what that's cool that's cool
i've never heard you make that
that's cute but yeah man i think the
thing that i'm the most excited about
is feeling the baby move because right
now i'm at 12 weeks and i read that the
earliest you can feel like flutters or
any type of movement inside is 13 weeks
which is next week so i'm like oh my god
i hope i could feel
a little something i don't know i mean
this week i have been feeling some like
things that kind of do feel like
flutters like like fleeting little
movements inside but like with my actual
hand i can't feel it on the outside it's
just from within that i could feel it
but i think what i'm most excited about
is like feeling an actual like kick and
then and then having you feel a kick
yeah on a high five
high five the baby yeah a little
astronaut high five
yeah give me some damn pound yeah i
can't wait for that
okay so i was just laying
here like sitting very
very bad posture on this chair and
i felt the baby kick i totally felt a
kick
i felt the baby like right here it was
just like boop
but now i'm trying to feel it again and
i feel movement inside but not on the
outside anymore but i totally felt the
kick oh my god this is so crazy i wish
casey was here he's fixing me up lunch
right now but i don't know this position
i know this is really bad i probably
shouldn't be sitting like this but this
is how i felt a baby kick
it was hurting my back though i should
probably sit up
okay
yeah 13 weeks and ever since last week
i've been feeling a lot of little
flutters inside but just now i've felt a
really strong like boy
so i'm like oh my god baby's first kick
the baby's first kick
that's so cool can't wait till i'm
bigger and then really get to see all
the kicks get my butt kicked from within
all right so he's back
thank you honey burrito burrito
okay so i felt our baby
yeah yeah look i was laying like this
and then like right here
i felt a little kick
so maybe you can feel something
oh
this is where i felt the kick like right
there
[Music]
got it i don't know
i feel something really
maybe it is the baby come here man
what's up what you guys doing feeling
the baby kick you want to try to feel
yeah dang it's bigger than yesterday
yeah
oh wow really you feel something yeah
already i felt i felt something
i don't know if it's like your stomach
or something like your intestines no my
intestines are like up here oh okay well
down here is like the baby yeah that's
the baby movement then let me see i
could hear it like it's like yeah like
it's like when you're an apple watch
when you put on braids
[Music]
the haptics i can't tell if i
feel it moving or just
feel it growing
that makes i feel something i literally
feel something do you feel clever on the
inside do you feel that
what do you feel like describe the
feeling i feel like just something's
moving inside like if i had to make this
sound like
like like grumbling noises rumbling i
mean i am hungry so i'm like i'm not
sure if it's like just you or if it's
like something else like a baby
something else like a baby i think you'd
be like
ruby gaming alive
player
five has entered the chat
oh i don't play four oh yeah what the
heck i can't math
i heard that i have something wrong with
that
that's true you can correct me
player four what am i talking about
player five yeah belly totally chopped
out huh
only in this position when i get up it's
like more flattered it's so weird
because sometimes
it's um
it looks like a belly belly and then
sometimes it looks like i have nothing
so whenever the baby wants to show
itself yeah it's like i'm here and then
no i'm hiding
how cute you feel it
you feel the baby
he's praying i wonder if he knows that
like you know how like animals can tell
someone's pregnant and they can smell
the
hormones and the pheromones and all
sorts of moans i wonder if he if you're
like
admitting enough of it for him to be
like yeah you're pregnant yeah
something's off with you lady you know
maya's been acting different with me so
i think she knows a woman's intuition
you know
[Music]
all you do is exercise and eat exercise
and
and eat around like an astronaut
that's so fun
a fun life
[Music]
oh my god we're feeling the kitchen
it's got the baby's soul feet i know
isn't it cute i felt it wait come back i
think it's getting camera shy the baby
kept moving and we just felt finished
filming big mood
and i'm like come here the baby wake up
again it's crazy that if you like open
the door
i have it too i have the the scar door
yeah from my exit just like roll up the
blinds
like hi it's so cool
that's crazy it was like a microwave
yeah like where you turn the light
inside that's true
well
i didn't listen
you missed her reaction i'm very special
i could fake it for you but i don't want
to i want to wait till it's really there
[Music]
you